Good experience,
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day
you gotta be in shape.
How many guys can you shoot with?
Right.
Those are tough to.
I've seen.
I've seen really big guy is not going to pull just because it's an awkward and
yeah,
it's a different deal
that feel that you're used to that.
That's fine.
Cool.
I like this because you can really get a good grip to all four fingers as
opposed to like the thing wrapped around.
I'd have to see because normally you don't want to grip it [inaudible] like I,
I don't grip it at all because when you're gripping it,
that's one more thing to like.
I mean if I'm gripping this,
that's,
you can have pork on there and it's gonna.
It's gonna to pull it,
to pull it.
Right.
But I wonder,
are you still gripping when you're just relaxing to.
Yeah,
he's,
as you know,
you want to be as relaxed as possible.
Yeah.
Don't come up to just put it here.
I don't know.
I just feel like with this second round,
give it good.
Well yeah,
and you're used to it.
It was nice to be here.
That's fine.
Cool.
So did you get a factor over a spider in this way?
Because they don't make a spider at 90 pounds with that carbon and with the it's
long.
It's long.
So this is 30 inches and it's aluminum.
They,
they just didn't want to do a 90 pounder and that they thought there might be or
they never said why,
but probably the engineer just sat there might be too much riser torquing or
whatever that much pounded show.
They don't even give me that one for people.
No,
no,
no.
This is why.
And everybody's,
Oh you don't need to shoot 90 pounds in the bows bowser so efficient.
I'm like,
as much as I want.
And
I'm like,
it's 300 horsepower.
Good within $600 product.
That's my monkey mindset.
Yeah.
Anyway,
I just think,
you know,
if you're going to
shouldn't have had the chance to kill you,
you know,
you go into the woods with like glocks and like a fucking Samurai sword or some
shit,
like five miles away and then you shoot it and then you set it up.
So it's like big and scary when in reality it was like drinking water and taking
a shit but at the same dust as a pig from to home ranch fence up here guys,
we were upstanding.
I'll share with shot for the teeth on that motherfucker.
These things are tough to when you eat them
game.
This I shot,
this one says to home ranch and so like a hour and half of it's a big fucking
swamp.
It looks like that thing
like or recommend your tongue.
It's not gaining.
It tastes good but they're all muscle the muscle and you have to marry the shit
out of me.
Like the Loin pork,
pork loin.
It's like the softest.
Most tend to have a regular pick.
But I'm like a wild pigs.
I eat a bodybuilder because like my kids were like why is this shit?
So Chili
is everywhere.
It's fighting over a mate which playing other people for like pissing territory.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
And they have so many of them.
This one branch is 50,000 pigs,
$50,000 and they have at least 16 outlines,
maybe 20 mountain lions.
They don't even know how many they have,
but they've got like a bunch of pictures from this one,
the pond where the animals come to drink and they have like a bunch of different
model lines.
I could at least 16 of them that I take pictures with this camera trap.
They have their
50,000 pigs.
Twenty minute live me.
That is fucking.
That's crazy.
Wild Africa shit.
Pigs will kill you to pluck you out of the.
Well the big ones will,
they'll cut you up for sure.
You know even if you get away those tasks is very dangerous,
but people certainly not from Pitt.
I saw when I saw this,
this was like a water buffalo and it's baby was getting eaten by like two lions,
jumbos baby and distinct.
Just put his head down and they have like this specific trip where they put
their horn almost as if it's rubbing the ground.
Like you can't get low enough to the.
He was rubbing the foreign across the ground and as soon as he felt it near the
cat,
he just pulled it up and I'll fucking full grown bitch line flew in the air.
Is that a fucking water was cut from the.
He'll do almost a had a hole in here.
But when you saw it,
he had cooked the skin itself here because the skin is so tight,
the skin and this should just flew in the air.
So you fully flew by skin ripping documentary.
Relentless enemy get.
Yes,
I've watched it.
I've watched it like completely for like two months straight.
Then it's like,
it's the uh,
the water buffalo and alliance ships just trapped on an island by himself,
you know,
and the only thing they could do was fucking bang out.
It gets to the point where I was at a point where they're just like,
fuck it.
It's part of the thing like we know you're going to get one of us and shit like
that.
So letting you know,
it's just gonna happen.
It was a home.
So I kinda like la gangs in the nineties.
It's way crazy.
Like father knows best and then right after I will slip don't ad is when the
footage came out of the,
um,
the alligators in the same situation.
What was that called again?
Oh yes.
It's the triangulation.
What was the alligators?
Alligators fighting over to delegate or water buffalo shit.
The lion was cracking down
and they were all trying to get like a.
An animal.
Yeah.
They're like fighting over the issue that I see that I love to watch his killer
whales when they unison what's illustrated.
That DNA is mostly related to peck animals like wolves.
They're smart as fuck,
man.
Those things come after the election is this.
They showed them keeping a seal alive for like five,
six hours and what they say,
what sort of blue moon after they're done biting it and flipping it in the air
and giving it to the baby,
they'll let one go.
Like once in a blue moon when I had to,
I don't know how to fucking traumatized that type of must be traumatized,
but every single one of them gets thrown into fucking air.
Flipped around for like four or five hours to show the baby how to do it because
they always have like four big like adults and then they always have like a baby
with them to teach and the baby does Elisha to you think that he's not working
to working.
You can see them pop up like that.
Just to remind the seal.
You don't come this way too.
Did you ever see the one where they had them on the Ice Shelf?
They had to
weigh in on one side and making them slide towards them and they were teaching
the baby how to do it.
It was fine and as soon as he fell in the water,
that was probably night night done.
Shut down the city for Nico to smart man.
Keeping them in the cage,
keeping them in a fish tank like that.
It's just wait for it to us that slavery
slavery,
just because they don't understand what they're saying.
We pretended not just like almost like people.
I know.
Some dumb fucking people that I would think like a dolphin will probably smarter
than really fucking dumb.
Killer went up probably a lot of them.
They're really smart man.
We just don't think of them as smart because we don't see them altering their
environment like we do,
but if you pay attention to everything else,
language,
family,
they have with good companions for life.
They stick together with these parts.
They have different dialects in different regions.
Might as well be people,
man,
we're just.
We're just saying they're not people because they don't change their
environment,
but their smartest fucking people.
Man.
They're just.
They're living in a different world,
but they don't wear nothing new.
They don't wear anything.
They don't know.
They don't build houses.
They already got some flossing on
a rolled up.
Rocking some shit though.
You'd think so different about them.
There were closed.
We were except Tuxedo.
Everyday though took seed.
I can wait to see what we're so goofy if they were wearing the shit that they
killed it,
like,
oh
well that has a giant horn on.
We came out with that.
Is this cane
like
Unicorns?
There's just.
Sometimes they have one.
There's one that has to,
which is crazy.
Which is why they were mistaken for like seeing animals and in Scandinavia they
used to sell the horn as like a fake unicorn bar and there were all kinds of
shit.
Then it makes perfect sense when you look at.
Imagine what was in the water 10,000 years ago.
People didn't even know.
They had no idea what was out there.
Like now we've only studied 90 percent of your social back then what they one,
one percent and I didn't know then
they had no idea what was in there and you could go out there for fucking days
and days.
Never see.
Sure.
And then there's things live underneath you the whole time.
Fuck fuck man.
That's,
that's the trippy shit of all time that people were willing to get that crazy a
few thousand years ago.
Nope.
No documentaries to watch,
you know,
know Jacques Cousteau,
but they just found that no company.
So giant squishy too.
Did you hear about that dude that just survived?
He was out at sea for over a year and his partner ended up passing away,
right?
He was like,
yeah,
she bought her some shit and family.
He's getting mad and he floated from like the Pacific coast of California.
He floated to like some feet,
pretty much pronounced him dead because he was gone for a year.
The rainwater and turtle blood,
whatever.
Stay alive for over a year to 18 months.
I was crushed.
I don't know,
it was floating.
He was in a bowl.
Him,
his boys were fishing on the boat and he's basically the only one to survive.
Those are the.
I ran out here the date and using shit pregnant two weeks ago.
Right.
I mean that it was out there a year.
Let's get
kettle bells.
You know,
this one is 50 pounds.
Fifty five pounds.
We have ones of 45 pounds,
70 pounds because tomorrow's a early dude could see she's,
she's really cool.
She's awesome.
Actually follow her.
She's a great artist.
Oh cool.
That'd be fun.
But um,
you can get a 35 pound one 70 pounds to 55 and you're good man.
That's all you need.
And you could follow like a hundred different workouts.
Online.
Kettlebells are all about like using your whole body to the end range of motion
is differently if you're sitting on a stench how often either be on your back,
pushing kettle bell,
swinging and controlling the weight.
It's all about having a hold of the weight and controlling in working out with
it and making you do like a long reps that like translates to work.
Like if you were like physical work,
picking things up and moving things or grappling or any,
any athletics,
it's your whole body working together to control one thing.
Notice the whole body working in one motion.
Not like doing bench perhaps or doing curls.
It's whole body listening,
stabilizer muscles and balance everything.
Oh yeah.
All your core.
Especially shit like that.
Like windmills,
like anything where you're like,
you'll do like a whole series of these swing Khakis.
I just keep going,
Joe got to go
and it just gets you tired.
Like real work.
They're getting me tired.
Watching my shoulder would pop down already.
Now he's getting into great,
but doing shit like that builds full body strength.
No,
no,
no.
You're writing core.
The little muscles around here,
little tiny translates to work.
It translates to like a sport.
Fucking crazy stuff.
Get a couple of those and that's all you need.
Experience trying my day job,
get podcasts all day.